it's got the largest cast in cash prize
in TV history but is squid game The
Challenge even legit here's why some
contestants say the game was rigged from
the start anyone who watched Netflix's
hit 2021 South Korean drama squid game
knows that the fictional dystopian game
in question wherein 456 people desperate
for financial help fight to the death
for a $4.5 6 million cash prize is
brutal and unforgiving according to a
reports in Rolling Stone from February
2023 the streamers reality competition
show based on the series and offering
the same cash prize was if not lethal
also pretty
[Music]
brutal not only were filming conditions
during one specific game reportedly
horrible but some former contestants
made claims that the entire thing was
rigged for their part Netflix and its
co-producing Studio Partners deny claims
of a fixed game telling Rolling Stone
any suggestion that the competition is
rigged or claims of serious harm to
players are simply untrue we've taken
all the appropriate safety precautions
including after care for contestants and
an independent adjudicator is overseeing
each game to ensure its fair to everyone
but some contestants were exceedingly
blunt about what went down when they
spoke to the outlet one said it was just
the crest meanest thing I've ever been
through we were a human horse race and
they were treating us like horses out in
the cold racing and the race was fixed
so how was the race fixed exactly one
part of the expose claimed that during
the filming of the red light greenl game
some contestants successfully crossed
the Finish Line only to still get
eliminated at their incfi squib packs
which simulate gunshots and Signal a
contestants elimination allegedly
exploded way after the fact that group
didn't take it well one contestant
recalled it really wasn't a game show it
was a TV show and we were basically
extras in a TV show we all know that
reality shows manipulate scenarios and
make careful edits to ensure certain
outcomes contestants on The Challenge
though have alleged that the onset
behavior from producers was nothing
short of egregious take this example
from a contestant who claims that she
was eliminated even though she got
across the red light green light Finish
Line with 5 Seconds still on the clock
it was then as she was waiting to leave
that she saw that a contestant and his
mother were still being filmed and not
only that but the show allegedly added
time to the clock off camera just to
feature the duo the contestant claimed
this kid is sitting at the Finish Line
he's crying and cameras are on him and
he's waiting for his mom they added more
time to the clock for her to get across
because she was one of the people that
they wanted to be in the show my mom she
was like a Superstar athlete like I just
feel like she's going to she's going to
last me and embarrassed me in front of
all my family regarding the 9-hour shoot
for the red light Greenlight game which
was filmed inside an airplane hanger
contestants made some extremely serious
accusations namely they said that they
were forced to maintain Frozen poses for
the bulk of the 9ine hours only moving
from time to time a condition made worse
by the fact that they weren't
appropriately addressed for the
allegedly freezing cold temperatures
inside the hanger the icy conditions as
low as 14 de F according to the Rolling
Stone report led to some contestants
getting sick and collapsing and while
Medics attended to to the Fallen players
people in pink squid game guard suits
would block the process from view so
everybody else could stay frozen in
place one contestant revealed people
were beating themselves up including
myself around the fact that you've got a
girl convulsing and were all stood there
like statues on what planet is that even
Humane it played on our morals and it's
sick it's absolutely sick other injuries
contestants say they incurred during
filming included a herniated disc a torn
knee tendon pneumonia and ear infections
one contestant told Rolling Stone that
despite the game's Origins a brutal
survival experience wasn't what they
were expecting it's not like we signed
up for Naked and Afraid or Survivor
where you're going to eat ants and it's
going to be Grim that was not the game
and another contestant mused the funny
thing is equality and fairness was the
main theme of the original squid game
was it though the competition depicted
in Squid game was a brutal predatory
exercise created by wealthy sadis who
treated human life with little to no
respect the contestants were to put it
lightly manipulated into participating
and were targeted due to their
precarious Financial positions not only
that but if they moved during red light
green light or lost a game of tug-of war
they were quite literally killed on the
spot none of this is to say that the
alleged misconduct on the set of squid
game The Challenge is acceptable in the
slightest it is to say though that
perhaps a reality competition series
based on such a terrifying and ugly
Prospect is sort of an ippy Concept in
the first place as another contestant
put it there's $4.5 million up for grabs
these people were willing to die someone
says I'm going home with this I don't
care what it takes I think the producers
wanted that they wanted people to not
think about their health to not care
about their
[Music]
safety